- WELCOME BACK
TO CAN I FINISH?
THINGS GOT PRETTY OUT OF CONTROL
ON THAT LAST ROUND.
THAT CANNOT HAPPEN
AGAIN.
TODAY, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE PROLIFERATION
OF TALKING HEADS
ON THE NEWS.
IS ALL THIS SQUAWK
ADDING UP TO SQUAT?
LET'S TAKE IT TO THE PEOPLE
IN THE TINY BOXES.
[shouting] LUKE BENNETT,
ANY THOUGHTS ON THAT?
- IT'S SIMPLY A GAME
OF MATHEMATICS.
IF YOU LOOK AT
THE SIMPLE FACT...
- EXCUSE ME.
- OF WHO IS CONTROL...
- EXCUSE ME! EXCUSE ME!
- OF THE MEDIA,
THE CORPORATE--EXCUSE ME.
- MAY I--CAN I TALK?
- LET ME FINISH.
- LET'S TAKE THIS ONE
OUT TO SEA.
CAPTAIN JACK!
- WHEN A BOAT SINKS,
EVERYONE BLAMES THE CAPTAIN,
LIKE ON THE TITANIC.
- EXCUSE ME!
- IT'S NOT ALWAYS YOUR FAULT!
- MAY I FINISH PLEASE?
- YES.
YOU CAN FINISH, MARK!
- IT'S GIVE AND TAKE.
- AND STUCK AT SEA
FOR FIVE MONTHS.
- I'VE HEARD WHAT YOU--
- LET ME FINISH!
- RIGHT, RIGHT.
BUT WHAT IS JOHN Q. PUBLIC
SUPPOSED TO THINK ABOUT THIS?
GO AHEAD, MEEK WOMAN.
- THANKS, JIM.
UH, WHAT I WAS TRYING
TO SAY BEFORE, UH, WAS--
- WHO CARES WHAT THIS DOG WOMAN
HAS TO SAY?
- EXCUSE ME!
MAY I FINISH? PLEASE?
- ALL RIGHT, LOOK, MARK
CAN'T TAKE YES FOR AN ANSWER.
[screaming]
MEEK WOMAN, I WANT TO HEAR
WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY!
- THANKS, JIM.
WHAT I WAS TRYING
TO SAY BEFORE IS THAT--
- TIME'S UP.
FLIP THE BOXES.
- DOG--
- THANK YOU, JIM. FINALLY!
THE METS ARE
THE WORKING-CLASS MAN'S TEAM.
- PENALTY BOX.
THE METS ARE OFF-LIMITS.
CUT HIS MIC.
WE GOT A TWEET HERE
FROM @AKABOBBYB.
HE SAYS, "NO DISRESPECT,
BECAUSE I RESPECT YOU,
BUT CAN I FINISH?"
WELL,
WHAT ABOUT THAT?
SHOUTMAN, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
AND PLEASE DON'T SHOUT.
- [shouting]
I WILL NOT STOP SHOUTING!
- YEP.
- EXCUSE ME, CAN I FINISH?
- DR. ARMOND,
WHY ARE YOU HERE?
- JUST LIKE DOGS HAVE A RIGHT
TO GET PLASTIC SURGERY,
I HAVE A RIGHT TO SP--
- OKAY, TIME
FOR THE CIRCLE ROUND.
MEEK WOMAN, SPEAK!
- EXCUSE ME, CAN I FINISH?
both: CAN I FINISH?
- JINX! ONE OF YOU
OWES THE OTHER ONE A COKE!
- [scoffs]
- OKAY, METS FAN,
YOU ARE
OUT OF THE BOX.
- EVER.
YOU KNOW, BUCKNER.
THAT WASN'T HIS FAULT.
- [stutters] JUST SPIT IT OUT!
THAT WAS METS POSITIVITY.
- JUST SPIT IT OUT!
- GUYS, GUYS.
WE NEED TO SEE THOSE BOXES
TURNED INTO DIAMONDS.
- EXCUSE ME, WHY IS THIS GUY
TALKING ABOUT BASEBALL?
- CAN I FINISH, LUKE?
- WE ARE OUT OF TIME.
EVERYBODY FINISH.
JUST DO A QUICK FINISH.
- I AM SHOUTING AT YOU!
- AH! HE'S IN MY BOX!
- FOLKS.
TWITTER ME AT--
[overlapping shouting]
HEY, I'M TRYING TO TELL THEM
THE TWITTER ADDRESS!
EVERYBODY KEEPS TELLING ME
IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THEY TWEET ME--
[overlapping yelling]
THE TWITTER--
- MAY I FINISH?
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M GONNA GET EVERY--
[overlapping yelling]
FORGET IT!
THERE'S NO POINT IN IT!
SOMEBODY'S JOB'S GOTTA BE
TO FIGURE OUT WHO TALKS WHEN!
I CAN'T DO IT
'CAUSE I DON'T KNOW HOW!
- I AM SHOUTING LOUDLY!